Everyone makes mistakes, even in a galaxy
far, far away.
Not even Jedi masters, Sith lords, or George
Lucas are free from the occasional blunder.
Star Wars ushered in a new era of digital
special effects and filmmaking, but the filmmakers
behind it all are all still human.
If you look beyond the lightsabers, it's apparent
in the mistakes and missteps you can find
in each of the movies in the saga.
And that's not even counting Jar Jar Binks,
nature’s biggest mistake.
“It’s embarrassing.”
Keira who?
There's a reason people forget Keira Knightley
was in The Phantom Menace.
The British actress plays Sabé, a quiet handmaiden
who serves as the costumed decoy of Natalie
Portman’s Queen Amidala throughout most
of the movie.
Being a fake-out queen isn’t much of a role,
but the fact that Knightley's first name is
misspelled in the end credits probably doesn't
help either.
Those handmaidens don’t have very good luck.
“Padme, clean this droids up as best you
can.”
Head of the class
Although the Jedi younglings that Yoda trains
in Attack of the Clones are capable of some
astounding things, one appears to be just
a little more capable than the rest.
The little guy with the reptilian face who
starts the shot out near the middle of the
group is suddenly behind everyone after an
angle change, and then at the head of the
class after a quick cut.
It's probably just a continuity error, but
it could also be a pretty solid Jedi trick.
We’ll never find out.
Thanks, Anakin.
The disappearing jacket
Who knows what weird stuff you might find
inside a Jedi's home?
When Luke Skywalker swings by Obi-Wan Kenobi's
hut to try out his dad's lightsaber in A New
Hope, there's initially a jacket hanging from
the archway.
“This is a weapon of a Jedi knight.”
But after a cut, it's nowhere to be seen.
Did you miss it?
Must have gone to the dark side… or maybe
just the laundry.
The vanishing stormtrooper
In A New Hope, Obi-Wan Kenobi uses the Force
to convince stormtroopers that C-3PO and R2-D2
aren't the droids they're looking for.
“These aren’t the droids you are looking
for.”
But apparently, he could've just made them
disappear.
After a quick cut, the stormtrooper who was
right behind them suddenly vanishes.
Jedi trick, or impromptu lunch break?
Vader's quick change
During Darth Vader and Obi-Wan Kenobi’s
epic lightsaber battle at the end of A New
Hope, Vader gets pretty mixed up, and not
just because Obi-Wan evaporates into his own
robe.
“Nooo”
The buttons on Vader’s chest plate first
appear on the right, then they switch to his
left.
If only switching between the light and dark
sides were so easy.
Model misbehavior
The battle sequences on Hoth in The Empire
Strikes Back were larger than life, especially
because of the Empire's enormous Imperial
Walkers.
But looking back, some of the practical special
effects seem a little crude.
After Luke blows up the guts of one of the
massive war machines with a grenade, it comes
tumbling down.
Watch the back leg.
You can't miss the pole used to tip over the
miniature model, which comes out of the ground
and quickly retracts.
Not so slick.
Millennium flyby
George Lucas took special effects light years
into the future, but his team at Industrial
Light & Magic were learning on the job.
To depict asteroids, they used everything
from old shoes to potatoes.
In a view from the helm of the Millennium
Falcon during The Empire Strikes Back, you
can briefly see the Millennium Falcon fly
past itself.
It’s blurry, but that’s Han’s ship doing
a barrel roll from an unused scene.
That’s some impressive flying.
Crazy carbonite
Being frozen alive in a block of carbonite
can't be a ton of fun, but Han Solo seems
to have found a way to let loose.
His arms are clearly bound behind his back
when he’s lowered into the freezing chamber
in The Empire Strikes Back.
But when he's set free in Return of the Jedi,
Solo's arms are somehow unshackled.
What really happened in there?
Lando flips
Lando Calrissian borrows a perplexing move
from Darth Vader during his appearance in
Return of the Jedi.
As he playfully calls his pal Han Solo a "pirate,"
Calrissian is suddenly shown wearing all his
clothes the opposite way.
Rey makes her point
In The Force Awakens, it's pretty clear that
Rey is far from an ordinary young woman, but
at one point, she does something pretty extraordinary
on board the Millennium Falcon.
As she and Finn are repairing the ship, she
points at something with her right hand in
a close-up.
The wide shot shows her pointing with her
left.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
Star Wars mistakes you’ve caught...